all right they go look at that they get
these suckers all the time
Nephite they going to go show them Scott
Baio's houses some they just pull
up to like a hotdog stand
oh they must have knocked it down look
if there's anybody in that van look
remotely excited do I love about it
because they all know that we're talking
about him right now there's nothing they
can do but something's different the
Midwest the polite microphone right
there they goes Jerry Lewis right there
right there that's what it's like in LA
they just walk down the street we don't
walk up what we're not we're not
affected by celebrity out here the way
you people are is this good huh
but I've got really kris kristofferson
Kris Kristofferson just hanging out
thinking about us it's necklace not EMS
that dude from The Big Lebowski narrated
whatever the his name is Sam Elliot
who's also in masks who a lot of people
say I look like which is very offensive
to me as a redhead Stoltz Eric
Stoltz now no but they're they're saying
I look like literally Eric Stoltz with
the makeup on saying I'm ugly
oh yeah uh whatever that girl is
who cried because she's going to jail
there she goes she's going to jail right
now leave at least a low hand but your
name Lindsay Lindsay Lindsay Lohan that
was Pam Dawber
she played Mindy on Mork & Mindy they
just all over the place here and you
know all kind to star going on Ted
Danson Ted Danson just said hello Rita
Rudner just went in there to get a
palm read this
the tare tickets outside this parking
garage and that's one of the chicks from
facts of life the ugly one that ugly one
there yeah she really fell off by the
carload of jackasses coming by look how
unexcited they are that's one of those
deals where all of a sudden you realize
you're in a tourist trap and you can't
get out although the guy's just begging
you to get out with no roof so
the guy who played the postman on cheers
Jeffery out right right in the blue
that's uh that's John Ratzenberger
we
is back on there for a long time you
know what's great is when you do
this like that people know you're
filming them then you got that stupid
trying to play it off flip in your face
yeah the weather
hey goes Kevin James I'm going to do
another season of King of Queens with
the method actor he actually
bought that UPS truck that's how much
money he has you know I don't
have that kind of money but I'm hanging
onto the dream you know you hear all the
car horns beeping as people drive by did
acknowledging my vh1 level of celebrity
you know is it hard is it hard it is
sometimes it is sometimes but you know
you learn to deal with it it's just how
it is people please stand back stand
back please
doing a good documentary I don't like to
do Camaros we got to get the Challenger
that looks better anyway
that's who is that over there that's at
checkout who's the dad on eight is
enough
I don't know
look at that pitbull coming up here see
that's good to get its mouth opens in a
relaxed mode that's what you want you
don't want to freaking out like my
dog
you know my dog Wilma stay in a
landscape or the other day was a quick
ugly moment if that guy was a legal
alien I'd be in court right now
Ed Begley Jr still into the environment
not driving down the street there's all
kinds of celebrities out here you know
so I don't know why you guys read Us
Magazine all you got to do is stand here
they did this coming down the street so
that's it I hope you enjoyed the tour
The Comedy Store and I'm going to start
drinking